maybe I should have started at an image
because it actually falls out a bit
quicker and a bit simpler than the other
ones okay so start off in exactly the
same way okay but we have to note the
restriction which is - power to plan -
this time we are not inclusive okay all
right now what's the derivative the
derivative with respect to Y is okay now
you turn this over right in order to get
dy/dx and you might think oh that's a
reciprocal I write it as cos squared
okay which which would work okay but
remember what our goal is right I want
to get this back in terms of X I want to
get back to tan right so close squared
is actually going to step away from 10
SEC squared is actually a better option
so I'm gonna leave that as 1 upon 6
squared now what is the identity that's
gonna be useful to us here yeah and I
don't need to fuss around with any plus
or minus here which is nice because I
don't have a square root in bold yeah so
I can just go straight here ok done
that's it I think
all right so if at this is the simplest
of a lot No
now why did I bring the restriction Shh
oh wait wait this shouldn't really have
to raise my voice to someone who's four
meters away from me right thanks
oh you guys know me I don't mind talking
but if it's if it's that kind of talking
which stops actual communications that's
probably inappropriate the question was
about the restriction right so this time
here why do I know the restriction I
only know that because well this only
equals this I can only go from here to
here if I include it because if I don't
then I've got the whole lot which is not
actually ten of us okay but do I need to
bring the restriction him back into play
the answer is no because there was no
squarey involved so I didn't need to
decide between plus or minus okay which
is why I had to bring in before so
that's why that's why the domain the
range restriction doesn't reappear
because it's not important right now
before I tell you about what's on your
desk
okay the forms that you actually will
see most frequently I'm not the duty to
say most closing most autonomous but
ones involving general okay so I'm gonna
show you what they are we gonna work
what what the derivatives are together
okay if air is a constant okay this is
chain or Kia right hmm how good are we
doing this we know you've just written
down what the derivative of just regular
sign University is okay so how would it
work if I were doing a chain rule here
well chain will you do the inside then
you do the outside so what's the
derivative of the inside if it is just a
constant all right good okay now what's
the derivative of the inside so I just
in the inside the outside it's one on
the square root of now watch out because
this is chain rule right if we go under
four-way and done this on the
substitution at this point here we were
right like you swear right where u is
equal to
okay so this is not going to be x
squared here it's going to be X on a all
squared okay now I'm just gonna skip
that line and go straight there because
I wonder if you can see why that will be
useful to me right see I have this a at
the front okay I can simplify things by
bringing it inside
underneath the square root sign but once
it goes underneath it becomes a sweater
right so this is one on this square root
of a squared minus x squared because a
square there and the a squid there
pencils okay now you'll also see this
form y equals 1 over a 10 universe of X
now you might wonder why do they stick
another 100 day out the front ok let's
see what happens ok when you do the
derivative okay I've got one on an a
eyes are close to the front so I'll just
write that down and now I initiate chain
rule right so I do the inside which is
one a day okay now do the outside now
what's the derivative of tan inverse
it's that except instead of 1 plus x
squared I'll have just like here x
squared on a square okay now you can see
why they often looks like this extra one
on a at the front because now I have an
a squared here which again will do the
same sort of can't sleep thing so that's
one on a swim plus x squared